l'anorgation comment ça soigne ça dépend
de la cause en 95% des cas la cause elle
est psychologique donc il y a 1000
façons de soigner ça d'abord il faut
accepter le problème faut pas gâcher son
énergie à s'énerver contre quelque chose
qui est là de toute façon on va en avoir
besoin pour régler le problème justement
plus on se met la pression plus on se
stresse avec l'absence d'orgasme plus on
sécrète des hormones du stress et celle
là c'est les pires ennemis de l'orgasme
ensuite parlez-en avec une ou avec un
professionnel pour identifier la cause
et la traiter et puis aussi parce qu'il
peut vous donner des exercices concrets
pour vous aider à retrouver le chemin de
l'orgasme parlez-en avec votre ou avec
vos partenaires expliquer la situation
discutez-en ensemble et puis profitez-en
pour rassurer votre partenaire s'il y a
besoin profitez de ce que vous avez
quand même il y a un rapport sexuel ça
se limite pas à l'orgasme donc en
attendant de régler ça si c'est possible
concentrez-vous sur ce qui marche bien
le plaisir que vous ressentez le plaisir
que vous donnez etc